[Musique]
jean david pelletier est un fleuriste
pas comme les autres ces fleurs sont en
papier une passion mais par nécessité
durant le 2ème confinement j'ai perdu
mon emploi au début de la pandémie fait
que pcu en attente on sait pas ce qui se
passe
fait le tour de netflix était morose et
où je me suis mis spontanément à
bidouiller avec du papier à faire des
fleurs puis à les mettre sur facebook
c'est pour faire plaisir au monde qu'il
est en pleine réaction contre le wa wa
un passant devenu un gagne-pain
fleurissant ses créations aux mains
bornes et les mannequins de l'expo jean
paul gaultier à dubaï cet hiver c'est
plus qu'incroyable sa place à rendre
compte de film monstres mais non plus à
ce jour sept cent mille visiteurs qui
ont vu les fleurs à dubaï à l'exposition
universelle jean paul gaultier
moi même le plus épaté tous a
méticuleusement façonnés à la main ces
fleurs qu'on peut parfumer soi-même
ressemble à s'y méprendre à celles qu'on
retrouve dans la nature et pas de risque
d'y être allergique je pas la reproduire
parfaitement je puisse kkr kkr
ressemblance mais dans son mouvement
dans sa texture il ya quelque chose
d'invraisemblable
peut-être pas politique mais c'est je
pense qu'on voit bien que c'est pas 100%
vrai mais on voit bien que c'est pas du
plastique du dollarama ya un travail et
une attention
marie malgorn cultive elle aussi des
bouquets de papier depuis plus de deux
ans cette graphiste de formation vend
ses créations en ligne et en boutique il
ya vraiment possibilité d'aller loin
dans la création parce qu'on peut
utiliser justement de la peinture de
l'aquarelle du pastel on peut utiliser
plein plein plein de médiums différents
ce qui fait qu'on se lasse pas c'est
jamais fini son ode à la nature est
exposé jusqu'à la mi juin au circ rôle
de pointe claire dans l'ouest de
montréal ont souvent je prends des
vraies fleurs puis je vais les jambes et
les pétales les étamines je vais essayer
de la disséquer et puis essayer de
reproduire au plus juste pas besoin
d'avoir le pouce vert il suffit d'un peu
de dextérité et d'imagination pour
cultiver un jardin fleuri toute l'année
ici n'est bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal